[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life and sometimes sex
for a long time i'm red and i'm link
this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are wrapping up sex timber
by answering your questions comments
concerns celebrations curiosities that
you sent to us using
ear biscuits around
sex timber which is leaked into october
yeah but it should be contained and um
we're going to be answering
some some fun questions
and
we'll see where this goes but
including but not limited to
um
have we
ever experimented with each other or
even thought about it sexually i mean
we've done lots of experiments we've
done science projects together we do
that regularly on the show right have we
ever experimented sexually with each
other it's a burning
burning
question that we are going to answer are
you referring to when i gave you
gonorrhea yep super gonorrhea as a
matter of fact i still got it it's a big
problem yep i'm just glad to not be
alone in it now uh yeah so i don't
actually okay whatever this is this
maybe we'll clarify do we have gonorrhea
this whole exercise has been a lot of
fun for me we've already expressed the
fact that there was a lot of trepidation
going into this
anytime we decide to pull a layer back
and become honest and vulnerable about
something especially something that
most people consider to be private and
like why would you talk about this
publicly do you guys go to parties and
talk about your sexual experiences no
not typically unless that's the point of
the party
um
but again i have heard of these parties
i've never attended never mind
but the one the ones that uh i've heard
about ultimately it was about selling
sex toys it was like like a pampered
chef for a dildo yeah yeah yep yep
pampered dildos this is my favorite one
of my favorite brands not a sponsor yet
but we did unintentionally write a song
for a sex toy company during our charity
live stream hilarious man twin tail toys
i think
got their own theme song the theme song
did not allude to that because we didn't
know that's what was happening just real
quickly before we get into uh this
this last uh you you you might want to
put on do not disturb on your phone
there oh yeah let me do that real quick
before we get into these
this last episode of sex timber thank
you for all your questions thank you for
engaging in the conversation with us
we're
each time we decide to kind of pull back
a layer is we are confirmed in our
belief
that illuminating these things and being
honest and vulnerable vulnerable about
them is only helpful to the community
around this podcast i think it's helpful
for us to kind of be able to share these
things
but what we see is that people are like
this led me to think about myself in
this way or to breach this
conversation or broach not breach but
approach this topic with my partner
and i i just believe
that when you bring an illuminating
light onto something the results are
positive when you try to keep things in
the dark when you try to keep things
behind closed doors
the results are just usually not good so
that's why you're like why would you why
do you guys talk about this stuff this
just seems like a
unnecessary spectacle
you're doing for attention it's like
well we know that it gets people a
little bit excited when we call
something sex timber and talk about sex
for a month
but really the the heart behind it the
intention behind it is to continue to
bring dialogue into
a subject that people are just kind of
afraid to talk about that if we would
just have freer conversation about this
stuff i think it could be beneficial to
to all of us i have really enjoyed
the conversations
um
especially having christy and jesse on
super proud of of them being brave and
and breaking the seal on joining the
podcast and thanks for all the positive
feedback that you've sent their way
uh and i know that they appreciate it
too and
i've appreciated the experience of
just feeling more freedom associated
with this topic and it's helped me
undo
more of and let go of even more of the
baggage i think that is the exercise of
coming out of purity culture from me
is being able to have these
conversations identify when there's
embarrassment or shame starts to like
percolate
and then say and identify as you know
what
actually that's not i don't have to feel
that way that's not that's not rooted in
where i'm at and where i'm coming from
now
so i've enjoyed that part of this i'm
also glad that i haven't seen anything
really stupid yet that i regret well we
got one left
okay
yeah because we want this to be helpful
and the last thing i want to do is like
uh just by again the disclaimer
presenting only our
experiences which are
in we have individual experiences but
they're very close but and they're very
very narrow in the spectrum of
experiences that people have related to
their own sexuality
and having sex
and
even without the context of purity
culture but also within that so that's
still what we're presenting
at this point and this episode will get
you know i try as much as i'm naturally
prescriptive when i when i talk about
things and i i try to be persuasive we
we have tried to stick with for the most
part this is our story this is our
perspective we're going to try to do
that with these questions because some
of them are just asking us oh could you
clarify this could you answer this
question about your personal life but
some of it is how do you think about
this thing now
and so again this is our perspective at
this point our perspective has changed
quite a bit about so many things over
the course of our lives and i expect
that it will continue to change it's
pretty fluid and evolves but this is
where we're at now on these things so
and i think that
as i said with christie and jesse
like because
sex is not the thing that
is it's it's not just a topic that comes
up all the time within the the uh
trajectory of my spiritual
deconstruction and
my entire
world view shifting and i wouldn't say
my lifestyle hasn't shifted but the but
the foundations of it have shifted
practically it plays out pretty
similarly i'm still
i'm i'm an evolving link but there's
still a lot of me that's still the same
but
as i've come to grips with
self-discovery in the new me i think
that
sex
views on sex lag
at least a little because
there's only certain times when it's
appropriate to talk about it and it's
not as it
versus other beliefs like whether that's
how do you interact with hell or
et cetera so
i will very much acknowledge i'm still
on an active journey of re-figuring this
[ __ ] out
all right so let's get into it kimbo
jimbo
asked us do you think your strict
upbringing limiting you to one sexual
partner for you and your wives was a
good thing
now 20 years into marriage
or do you wish
you had more experience going into it
one of the ways that i process this
question is
do i want
the current reality to be different
and that's an easy no and
for me and i know this might not be the
case for everybody for me that's no like
i am very happy with my relationship
with jesse i'm very happy with our
sexual relationship we have a vibrant
and fulfilling sexual relationship and
our communication about that is open
and i think we it has our sexual
relationship has evolved and gotten
better over time as we said in the last
episode i feel like we're having the
best sex that we that we've ever had
now
so the idea of going back and being like
oh would you like to bring more sexual
experience into your marriage
my answer is well
i can't answer that question
in in because i'm happy with how it
turned out
but i don't again i don't think that is
for me a prescriptive thing to be like
so therefore you also should not bring
any sexual experience and you should
also bring
a complete sexual or a lot of sexual
ignorance into your relationship and
just figure it out together for us
because of the nature of our
relationship and the nature of our
communication style
and also kind of our sexual disposition
we were able to grow together in kind of
a beautiful way
but there's just as many if not more
examples just from like my anecdotal
evidence that is out there
of people who didn't bring any sexual
experience into the marriage and then
because of some personality stuff or
some
specific hang-ups that lack of
experience and lack of comfort with each
other sexually
led to
maybe
years and years of sexual
non-satisfaction or maybe sex like no
sex at all
so i can't only speak from my own
experience i would not go back and
change it um yeah i i feel the same way
i think that
because christie and i were
we were
comfortable
like really learning about sex together
and being open and communicative about
it it it didn't didn't end up being a
problem it actually became
fun for us to learn
together
and i think you know
i remember there were these like
the conversations we had before
our wedding night
it's like okay i'm gonna i'm gonna bring
up oral sex and it's like what if she
says
she's like grossed out by it
like i'm a uh i'm a little afraid
because i mean i guess i've heard of
that from people so i and i've part of
oral sex i'm really exci i've heard of
people being grossed out by it yeah
people been grossed out by it so i'm
like i really hope that she's not and i
remember that moment of like i'm gonna
i'd rather know now than have to figure
it out
when i'm like i want to go go in for it
go down go down on it yeah uh or and
vice versa and hope for that if you're
upside down it's going i was relieved
that we were we were both excited and
open to that
just do you know just the future was
spread out before us
so we were compatible in that way and so
we but if not that would require more
work so it was
we had fun learning
each other but the fact is we had a lot
to learn about ourselves too
and
it just kind of made it that that made
it part of our story i think the other
way you could maybe this is not the
specific question
but another question that kind of goes
along with it is
is there regrets just personally like do
i wish i would have had more experience
not so it would have made me a better
lover or so it wouldn't have helped our
relationship but it's just like hey i
only had sex with one woman ever
i'm curious about that i'm curious about
what it would be like to be with an
another partner of course i mean i mean
i i just
am
and it's kind of like
when i'm on my deathbed and i'm like you
know i never saw the eiffel tower it's
like well would i like to have seen the
eiffel tower if the circumstances were
right for that well a better analogy
would be like is there a famous cave of
some kind okay yeah
uh what's the most famous cave in the
world
because i'm trying to make an analogy
for a vagina you got the linville
caverns which are not that famous and
i've been to them
it was kind of a disappointment okay see
there you go
it's like
sometimes it's not never mind it's built
i've never gone through the that tunnel
underneath the english channel
well i'd like to do that but you know
what i'm i'm sitting here dying on my
death bed that's why it's called a
deathbed it's really just my bed but now
that i'm dying we're calling it a
deathbed and i'm saying you know what i
am i'm grateful for the life i lived and
i can see the beauty in the tunnel that
i did frequent
and i don't i and i can still be honest
and say what i've
is the idea of visiting another tunnel
appealing or intriguing yes but i have
no regrets in not going there because
hey you can't do everything in life you
can't see all the sites
and
by seeing those sites you don't know
what ramifications that would have and
who you are as a person and your
experience and it might would have
really screwed up
the
the cozy experience that i've
come to know and love and covet
that is my our own tunnel right
basically
again it kind of relates to the way i
was thinking about the question is like
in the context of my own personal
experience right in the in the tunnel
that i frequent
the the prospect of other tunnels will
because i'm a normal well i don't think
normal because i am a
sexually
active and sexually motivated man
um
yes the idea of other tunnels is
appealing and i wouldn't even say man
let's say person person well i'm just
speaking from my own experience
is what always going to be appealing and
my wife understands that like we're not
one of those couples that the idea or
even a conversation about being
attracted to someone else i mean hell i
dress up like jason momoa for her
birthday because she is sexually
attracted to jason mamoa and i know that
i get that i appreciate that and my way
of responding to that was to become
jason mamoa for her birthday right i i
thought it was funny i didn't you know i
played up in the video that like i was
like i can't believe that i'm the wing
man in this thing it's like this is
ridiculous because it's because it's
funny
i will say in the past like
years before that maybe decades earlier
um i would feel uncomfortable when you
and jesse would talk openly about your
like celebrity crushes
for example or saying things in
conversation about how how hot you
thought somebody else was
um i came to realize that for me
some of that discomfort
was
well first of all i'd realized that that
would translate into judgment of you
but that was really i came to realize a
defense mechanism covering up
the root of my response which was tied
into abandonment issues
and security issues so i wouldn't want
to
you know if christie brought up
something it might trigger in me an
insecurity that like oh she made a joke
about keith urban
you know
uh and i'm like
does that scare me
does that threaten me does that tap into
something deep inside of me that like
just an
honest statement about
acknowledging that somebody's attractive
all of a sudden means a whole lot to me
but exploring it leads to growth
so it's it's i
i think i've been a little envious that
you you could speak openly about that
because you didn't have that hang up but
it it brings up something that i
actually do need to work if abandonment
issues is something that i
am working on
and
but it takes acknowledging that so it
and it happened within that process a
little bit of course a lot of other
things too
um getting to a point
where you can have open conversations we
can be honest about within the context
of your relationship about like
the the human
feelings desires and urges you have but
then like acknowledging that and then
saying but this is this is what i'm
doing because i love and prioritize you
and this is what the decisions we've
made as a couple
you know it's it's much it's very
rewarding
to have those conversations it's
difficult and it's scary but it's better
than just keeping it to yourself
and then
your partner's walking on eggshells
about things yeah you know so in that
sacrifice there there is a a sac because
i think
the old rat who was listening to the new
rat would be like oh he's setting
himself up to be able to do whatever the
[ __ ] he wants to do
right
literally that is not the case
it's it's ba it's it's moving to the
health framework like i said it can be a
little bit more complicated and complex
because it varies from person to person
that's one of the biggest shifts that's
happened as my worldview has changed
moving from a place where you believe
there is an objective morality that
applies to everyone in every
circumstance and it's a
one-size-fits-all to understanding that
individual decisions and it definitely
this is more of a post-modern way of
thinking about things but
you are a specific person with a
specific perspective in a specific place
and time
and what's most healthy for you is not
going to be the same as it was for
somebody else at a different place and
time
and i just think that
the idea
that
that doesn't mean that now you do
whatever you want to because i'm in the
context of a relationship with jessie
and i don't get to do whatever i want to
do right she doesn't get to do whatever
she wants to do because we are in a
relationship that involves commitment
and compromise right you don't you don't
just get to be like i have a desire
therefore i go and fulfill it and that's
the end of the story it's like no
everyone has desires that you need to
keep in check and that might be
understood and explained in a religious
context for a lot of people but that is
just a that's how
human
um that's how civilization functions is
by there being cooperation and
compromise so ultimately the idea of
like i've got this this thing that oh
this seems like it would be fun but
would it be best
would this be good for me would this be
good for us like that and be and kind of
to piggyback off of what you're saying
bringing those things out into the open
and being like well this actually does
seem fun to me or this i'm interested in
this having that conversation as a
couple so you can at least acknowledge
it so it's not just something that's
festering and growing on one side of the
relationship and then somebody breaks it
out and says i want to do this and
you're like well i wasn't ready for this
and but you're already already committed
to it in your mind and there's no coming
back from it
that's a problem and that will and i
think that's why so often
in the relationships that i've seen
where people have tried to sort of
redefine the nature of their
relationship they haven't ended well
because the communication broke down at
an early stage or the compromise ended
at some point this is some good stuff we
could do a whole podcast on that but
another question but first let's do an
ad yeah let's uh once you break out that
beautiful uh bag you have there
this
is the mythical grooming line we got
some
lotion in here we don't have any lube in
here
uh missed opportunity we got some clay
pomade you could probably use this could
you use this as loop this hand lotion we
got some beard bomb
you can't master i think a man can
masturbate with this
i'm just trying to stay on i'm
jenna's shaking her head she's like no
no no don't don't give that advice okay
we've got lip balm i'm not listening to
rhett we've got lip balm two flavors
candy milk and peculiar perfect peanut
butter peppermint this is some good
stuff we've got a brush yup i know you
don't brush it don't masturbate with
this uh you got some beard oil
hey it's oily
hey i mean this stuff's all natural but
i mean i don't think you can put it in
all orifices
i don't know why i'm talking about it i
know i'm talking about because i'm
unashamed
and there's a musical comb
you know i mean you can get a lot of
this stuff as a set you can get them
individually
uh you can get them on amazon amazon.com
mythical and you can go to mythical.com
and get this stuff super proud of our
cruelty-free
formulations that are highly rated
check them out groom yourself
mythical.com
okay
murphy murphy asks how did you approach
the talk with your kids well
interestingly i recorded it i've
recorded my talk
just let's just break the seal i'm going
to play but when you do this then my
story will not be as good so i should
tell my story you want to tell your
story first yeah because i mean you've
got a freaking recording
i'm not going to play the whole talk i
was just going to just i was talking to
lock just get into the conversation with
it but go ahead yeah so before we play
your recording which uh cannot be topped
uh i'll just go ahead and give a
precursor i remember chris and i decided
hey we need to talk to the kids about
sex i mean the older kids lily and
lincoln lando was
too young to have like a detailed
conversation of anything of that nature
but
we were sitting down at the dinner table
and i don't know if we had agreed that
that this was the particular time i
think i just brought it up
it was like dinner table huh yeah we had
eaten dinner and then the table was
cleared and then i like gave christy a
look if i remember correctly you made a
you did a sex talk as a family yes
without lando being there uh yeah i
think lando was dismissed from the table
he wasn't there he even if he was there
i don't think he he would have cared
um so yeah we lily and lincoln are two
years difference
um this is when we lived in the old
house the previous house when we had
just moved in there
so this might have been
uh let's see if this was eight years ago
they were ten and eight
so they were probably nine and eleven
because i know
that
you you told me that locke was nine when
you had the recorded conversation with
him 23rd so i'm sure we were talking
about it and i was like oh [ __ ] i went
in i need to have this conversation too
and chris and i were talking about it
had it at the dinner table
i don't remember how it started because
i didn't record it
i wish i would have you should have um
yeah because
you only have
if you do it right you only have to do
it once that's not actually true and
then you just play this play it for your
other kids that's right play the
recording well the sex talk is just
whatever their our approach was are if
they're
you you bring up the topic and then
as much as they're interested and
curious you engage their curiosity and
you answer their questions but you can
kind of we knew we would kind of feel
out when would be the point where they
were no longer interested and then
in subsequent conversations when it gets
good they don't want they don't want to
hear anymore they would get more
information so it was kind of breaking
the seal
on us being able to talk about sex
whenever it needed to come up it wasn't
a one-and-done deal right that's just a
good strategy um so i know that was our
mentality i can't remember a lot of what
we said
but i do remember very early on talking
about like the mechanics of
a penis goes into a vagina and then a
baby is made in the woman and
then it started to make sense and i do
remember using the
finger going into the
hole created in the fist symbol you mean
the eiffel tower going into the tunnel
underneath the
english channel yes really is what this
is i made this symbol would you i don't
could it fit right in i think the eiffel
tower is worse i looked over at christie
and the symbol she was making was
palms over face not uh
not what you want to communicate like
just like
double face palm looking down yeah but i
was like
this is going to be awkward let's go all
the way and so we were talking about it
and then
it kind of gave them chrissy and i both
kind of she kind of clarified and
corrected my mistakes i was probably not
right about everything
and then the it's not a finger and they
weren't saying anything
and then
we were like well
what do you think do you have any
questions
and there was silence
until lincoln spoke up and said
awkward
[Laughter]
but you talking about anything with your
family is kind of awkward
much less sex
yeah so i mean i've i think all of my
interactions have uh have felt like a
sex talk with my kids so how many sex
dinners have you had since then
so i you know i think it it again as we
talked about last week it's more this
mentality of like if sex comes up the
word shouldn't be whispered and well
let's just
these are legitimate questions let's
respond to them
as you are curious what i think is a
which i think is an excellent approach i
also think until you get to be a
teenager and then you've got to you got
to go to a next level but we can
excellent also an excellent approach is
just to record record your talk with
your kid
um i did this because i thought that it
would be funny to listen to later and
here we go here we are nine years later
um he did give permission right uh no i
mean oh yeah yeah not it not in the in
the time but yes now he has yeah yeah
i'm saying yes i told lock that i was
going to play a portion of this he was
like that's fine
um
so
i do want to preface this by saying so
this is august of 2013 and i'm thinking
about where i was at in my spiritual
life 2013 is really the year when i
stopped considering myself a christian
sort of the end of 2012 was when i was
having my most sort of like
intense like i just don't think i can
keep believing this fundamentally like
the fun the fundamental underpinnings of
jesus being the son of god and raising
from the dead and all this and yeah been
through that whole story but
kind of what you were saying earlier
a christian
sexual ethic was i hadn't even now
i hadn't for many years i'd been
uncomfortable with the idea that i i
wasn't i was uncomfortable with
christians who believed
that
you know being gay was wrong i i'd kind
of i that ship it sailed for for both of
us
right but
still as i thought about my own kids and
i thought about the sex talk it was very
heteronormative
like i'm going to talk about a man and a
woman i'm going to talk about a penis
and a vagina and i'm going to talk about
procreation and that's what the talk's
going to be yeah and i'm also going to
say
i'm not going to play the whole thing
i'm going to play a couple minutes it's
it's it's longer than that but
i also was like and this is something
that you should wait to do until you get
married like i was still saying those
things to lock at this time nine years
ago when i was presenting this uh so i
just want to acknowledge that i think
now a sex talk would kind of be like hey
here's sort of the procreation side of
the sex talk and how that works between
a penis and a vagina
and a sperm and an egg and the uterus
and all that stuff
but hey here's a different conversation
or an addendum to that conversation
which talks about sexuality and a
spectrum and that kind of thing that
wasn't where i was at at the time and so
my sex talk reflects that just wanted to
acknowledge that yep me too same in the
same place uh
so i'll just play this
okay
you said you told mom that you wanted to
know
about
how
a man and a woman
make a baby
what now tell me what did you what did
you say what are you wondering about
how they do it it's not like they can
just have one and
so
that's the form a certain way as to what
form from something
all right well you tell me how you think
it works
somehow
well how do you think it
happens a dna mixes from them
how does that happen
i don't know
pause it just guess so basically your
sex talk so far with locke is you trying
to get him to tell you how babies are
made did you not know uh yeah i needed
to have some help on that it's kind of
ironic well my strategy here was
uh
i know i'm recording this and so this
will be a funny way to start it yeah
to get his perspective but it also gets
him engaged in the conversation
how would the dna mix
because that's
kind of
and
true
kiss
well
okay
some physical reaction
a physical reaction
okay
this
this is going to blow your mind
okay
and it may be a little bit embarrassing
to talk about but listen look at me
you can talk about anything with me i'm
your dad
and i know a lot of things
okay
okay now you know that you have
a
penis
[Laughter]
it's not funny
you have a penis right
right okay
do girls do girls have a penis
what what do girls have
and like
hmm
what do you think they have
they always have something like a wiener
not least
well
at least you know how you have
penis which is like
a little finger down there
do you know what they have
they have like a hole right there yes
they have a hole called a vagina
okay
and the way that god designed this
is
that when a man and woman get married
they can
well basically the only the easiest way
to say this is
the man
puts
his penis the finger
inside
the woman's
it sounds crazy doesn't it
did you have any idea about this
when you get older not right now but
when you get older
um
there's there's something
other than p
that can come out of your penis
and it's called sperm
it's sperm it has your dna in it
okay i'm not gonna give you the whole
sex talk
wow he thought it was hilarious not
awkward which is great i mean you got
over hey that was a good that was a good
job and he you know like i think like i
said at the beginning he he had been
asking i love the fact that you were
asking him the questions because once
you tell him the answer you can no
longer get the com the full answer
because it's going to be informed by the
real answer so
that's the takeaway if i had to do it
again i would have totally gotten them
to commit
in the way that you did well that was
the reason we had the talk is because
locke has always been
super inquisitive and was asking lots of
questions i mean there were multiple
questions
for like multiple months and jesse was
like we have to have this talk and again
as you heard right there i was like god
when this is how god designed it and
it's you know when a man and a woman are
in the context of marriage i mean that
was again i wasn't even calling myself a
christian at that point but i was still
in a place where it's like i don't have
a new way of thinking about this and so
i'm not about to start telling something
different to my kids and jesse was in a
different place as well she was still
she was still calling herself a
christian at that time making it just
about how babies are made really
simplified it and it reinforced
the
yeah just the whole
heteronormative way of thinking about
things that we were yeah like you said
very much coming out of but it was like
oh my god how does it relate to a sex
talk was not
the first thing we were
trying to figure out when you're talking
about our eternal
destiny you know yeah and it was all
happening at the same time you're right
that was what was in the thick of it
yeah and and then as you think about the
you know shepherd who was five years
younger
but also very different he wasn't asking
all those questions and so my kids never
ask any questions the thing that
happened that sort of happened with
shepard is there wasn't a moment
it was more like older brother and also
a household where we were talking openly
about things and as lot got older
talking more openly and it was like okay
he's here and he's witnessing these
conversations and piecing things
together and so he just kind of figured
out as we talked about things in more
detail but the interesting thing is i i
think this kind of ties into some of the
stuff that we talked about with jesse
and christy of how has this conversation
evolved
as our as our framework has evolved and
i i mean i'm not going to answer the
question again but i mean just briefly
ultimately this has turned into a thing
where it's just like as opposed to the
way that it was
uh kind of for us which is like you've
got to protect kids from sex and you've
got to protect your children from you
got to tell them a very particular thing
but you want to kind of keep them from
messing themselves up i think the
mentality now is like how can i give as
much of the correct information
about sex to my kids and how can i i'm
not saying i'm not going to give them
advice
but i'm not telling my kids i'm not i no
longer have the ideological framework
that says you should wait until you get
married to have sex
but i'm not in a place where i'm like
sex means nothing and so therefore have
it whatever you want to at any time no
consequences no questions asked
um
but so it's so it's this ongoing
conversation that we continue to have
kind of to your point which is this
isn't something that we talked about
once this is something that we talk
about
quite a bit in our house now yeah
i think um
it's always fun to figure out this
parenting stuff yeah you know i think
that the girls said so much great stuff
about parenting the philosophy
we can move on uh andrew asks us did you
have any go-to music when you started to
have sex and are there any songs you've
listened to now when getting it on all
right so a lighter question here
um
i was listening to
this sounds tropish but i we had a berry
white cd
like greatest hits
and
there were certain
i would put it on at the top and then
somehow then i would have a point of
reference
with how how
mu how involved our love making session
was by how far we got into the cd
and it would actually help i would pace
myself to the tracks because it's like
oh i wanted to thrust to the beat
what you mean well first of all barry
white music is absolutely made to be
thrust too yeah and you can double time
it too oh my god it that's what the
music is made for
and it's a
it's a brilliant experience i mean he's
so good at it but it also is a little
bit
comical and ironic yeah it's wow yeah
and so it's because that's because
that's my i haven't gone back to barry
white in a while but i might break it
back out now when we started
uh using music in our sexual uh
you know
liaisons which was which right from the
beginning like we had like a little
music player or something on our
honeymoon
um
for some reason gypsy kings remember you
know that baby oh yes that was just like
we there was something about it that it
wasn't like sort of like cheesy and
ironic in the winter like barry white
might be now
it was
this feels like we're on vacation in a
foreign country and there's a bunch of
people on stage with a bunch of
different instruments
sort of singing things that we can't
really understand we don't want to
understand it we just want to be
speaking the language of love i
recommend specifically their album
called love songs which i which is the
one
um
i we listened to oh you actually you had
gypsy kings pulled up are you ready for
this yeah love songs it starts off with
una mo
[Laughter]
some other words in spanish
it's it's perfect but we actually don't
listen to like we don't do that anymore
because we wore that out so much um
this has been this has actually become a
little bit of a
i'm interested in your perspective we
haven't talked about this i'm interested
in your perspective now because with
spotify playlist which i'm
not great at
collecting things and i kind of see
playlists as collecting things because
it like takes this effort and this extra
layer of thought and so i'm using other
people's playlists
and no one ever gets the vibe that i'm
interested in and jesse is interested in
right because
jesse and i and jesse really really
doesn't want the like
this is somebody singing about sex like
it's like it just gets a little bit like
cheesy and you know what i'm saying like
it can be distracting in the least uh
and then there are some like there are
some couples that i think that's why
that's why other languages are great
we'll use like hard rock music something
like fight club like with dirt that
scene in fight club where she comes out
with a rubber glove on or whatever and
they're like listening like in my mind
they're listening to like this hard rock
music like we've never we've never done
that either
but then sometimes it can get too
like if you want to play like al green
it could be like well al green's not bad
actually it's pretty good sometimes it
gets a little too sweet
it's not made for that i want to i want
to say there's a sweet spot for me which
is just like there's a little bit of
sensual and there's a little bit of
sweetness but also we're both animals
you know what i'm saying and that's a
hard playlist to create and i just
haven't found it yet are you asking me
to create it for you uh no i'm just
asking you how you well like what is
your what is the genre at this point i'm
slow jam i need to do it for myself too
because the slow jams that go i don't
really like that like
90s
slow jam stuff well then you end up
getting r kelly songs in there and
that's problematic and you're like oh we
can't put you can't do that you don't
want our kelly songs in there i go to
the r and b
genre and then cl i i
if i got to make a quick decision i'll
just go back to the soul
playlist within the rmb but it's like
modern current
so you might get give me an artist um
like a usher
no he's not current well he's 20 years
15 20 years yes but he's i'm talking
about right now actually current like
you got a little bit of scizza
you got the right song and then you've
got some uh
um
beyonce's sister i'm embarrassed i'm
sorry solange solange i'm sorry solange
i know you hate that girl
and i i take it back and we know you're
listening
got some got some good stuff
um and those things start to lucky day
with an e on the end he's he's a current
r b artist that you can get some good
stuff from but they're not creating
entire albums that are just for sex like
barry white did so i i do need to create
my own playlist and i'll share it with
you and then you can move it around so
you can pace yourself and then measure
it's like all right this is
this is how i want to
you know i like to think of it like that
sometimes you just gotta like
do you i mean don't you do that
sometimes you're like all right slow
down change it up well you gotta let's
keep this is not gonna i think what
you're getting at is the number one
songs helps you understand like how long
you've been going and make sure that
you're not moving too fast right now i
told you about my smart situation that i
had with the lights and everything so if
i say hey google it's business time
it does start a playlist that i made and
it also turns all the lights red
uh which is pretty exciting for me
it's like i feel like i'm infrared
everything looks a little bit different
yeah well the internet is currently out
of my house
and you have to beatbox so make sure you
save a sex playlist to your your locally
so if the internet goes out you still
got that music is very important for us
because
we're i mean the way our house is
configured it's very nice that our
bedroom is like isolated from everybody
else's bedroom and the rest of the house
so
i mean
the
we we're running interference on like
kids coming and knocking on the door or
like hearing us but the music but the
kids know the music means you're having
sex we i don't know
we've never we never had a conversation
with our kids about like you know we
have sex like christy didn't we we don't
talk to to lily about that now i mean
she's out of the house and it's like by
the way next week i'm gonna
is when i'm gonna talk about
the whole experience of
lilly leaving home sending our first
child off to college
we're not gonna be talking about sex
next week but hey that's gonna be a good
one so come on back
you sex fiends
oh well um
i don't know if my my kids have been
very naive about all that but i know
we got a friend who's like i tell my
kids we're
mom and i are going to have sex and that
way we don't have to worry about them
knocking on the door
and i kind of wish i would have done we
haven't done that but i think our kids
know so
and our door doesn't lock right as i've
as i've established but music has been
important but last night
but the lando was at your house with
shepherd
of course lily's gone now and lincoln
was at a um a meeting
and it was the first time
at night i was like whoa nobody's here
it's just us
it's like we don't even need to play
music even though we don't have internet
played a little music but like
it
we never have the house to ourselves
so we have and we have this commitment
to making it work anyway but like i was
like man i'm gonna yell
like
we were in the midst of it and i'm like
i'm i can yell at the top of my lungs i
was i was literally sex yelling because
it was the first time you weren't making
legs and as long as i can remember
pleasure noises you were literally
saying what you just said a little bit i
didn't say this is still free
i didn't say that
but i was like yeah i mean we we talked
during sex and we sometimes i did it
because it was funny like she was
laughing and i was like
i can yell at my lungs and no one can
hear me i'm having sex in my own home
this is exactly what i was yelling last
night while having sex your neighbors
heard you which is fine
i i think that married couples develop a
way i mean if you want to talk about it
explicitly it's just like i do the
moment of orgasm
which you know uh can typically be very
loud
marry couples with children yeah have a
way of
basically climaxing and it's just all in
the face you know what i'm saying
you could definitely like dub this and
you would think they were making noise
but really they're just going
you could put a grunt and some moans
under there but they're not doing it
because they've been trained to not make
that much noise but then you go on
vacation and there's this adjustment
period to be like oh no no we can
actually
we can make noise now because our
children are not here but you've gotten
used to i mean the the sex can be very
intense but still you're kind of like
mouthing noises versus making noises
yeah and i think there's a transition
especially when the kids leave
for good i think there will that we will
become louder and louder uh
yeah even last night i was like man i'm
we're really missing out on this
the the vocalizations yeah oh
it does make a difference uh warbird
asks got a sex timber question for rhett
you are tall and your wife is not does
this present any sexual challenges and
or opportunities
um
you know what uh i don't think it
presents
either
i'm interested in the opportunities
uh but i have not run into the
challenges
just to be quite frank with you and i
don't know what it is about i mean i am
six seven and she is five three
but um certain things have to line up
but that means other things won't line
up like if you if your twig and berries
are lining up would you like a tunnel
would you be surprised it's gonna line
up would you be surprised to know that
uh we can be fully connected
and when i fully connected what i mean
is my penis will be in her vagina great
and we can be kissing at the same time
would you be surprised to know that
that's possible definitely well we do it
all the time
uh are you in some like
ish like some kind of like uh cow
yogurt
think about your necks
so first of all i have a back that can
bend a little bit and i have a head and
she has a head and we both have necks
and so if i'm bent a little bit and
she's like this and i'm like this mouth
tongue action
so
we can be making out and screwing at the
same time and do that on a regular basis
and it has never presented enough also
because your height difference is over
the course of your whole body
so if there is a
what is that difference a 14
16
inches difference it's spread out
proportionally yeah it's not like
there's a 16 inch difference between
where my penis and my mouth is if your
big toe was your penis
is from my head to my toe yeah so
there's probably only i'm only probably
accommodating for like seven or eight
inches of difference between my penis
and my mouth just to get geometric about
it and then i'm vending and there's yeah
so but to answer your question is the is
the height difference an issue and it
has not been an issue for us i hear that
loud and clear all right let's talk
about us
um toxic tonic asks uh have you guys
ever experimented with each other or
even thought about it
um first of all thanks for asking
because i think that apparently there is
a there's a lot of people who want to
know this and speculate
and i don't know if this is just a
tumblr thing
but definitely they are it's
concentrated they want to like assert it
as a reality
right it's not it's it's beyond
speculation it's an assertion that this
is a definite reality and there's of
course there's fan fiction written about
us that then our crew has gotten us to
read to uh
and i'm having the reason the only
reason i'm hesitant to answer this
question is because i actually think the
fact that people
firmly believe that we're having sex
with each other
might be the reason that they're fans
um and so i i really appreciate fans
so yeah i don't want to lose any fans
well but we i mean we're we're committed
to being honest too right and i want to
explore this completely but uh the
simple answer first is we have not
experimented
with each other
i've never experimented um
with with anybody
once i've seen your penis a couple of
times oh like while you like maybe that
we skinny dipped a few times with
friends yeah uh over the years i mean
talking about like high school yeah i've
seen i've seen many of my friends
wieners uh you know we've urinated next
to each other
um
i've never seen your erect penis i i've
never seen yours either
but uh yeah it was uh it was flaccid
here's what happened
here's what i will say the most physical
that we have been with each other
you've already seen it on the internet
like definitely we've cuddled with each
other we've gotten close to kissing each
other we may i don't have we kiss each
other on gmm i don't know no i've kissed
chase on gmm
um
right well we had a we we like kissed
with a
with glass in between kiss with glass in
between us
um but it was very quick and it wasn't
i it wasn't something that we were
excited the closest that we've been to
each other
physically has been something that has
already been broadcast on the internet
and yeah um there's lots of there's
photos there's many photos out there of
us kissing that are people taking things
that have happened
and photoshopping them together and
they're very convincing and look very
real
yeah but we've never done that but so
i'll go a step further and say i'll just
speak for myself yeah just yes because
you speak for yourself
um i
it just never crossed my mind
i mean it honestly has never crossed my
mind i think
people who think
that
we're
they
they experience our bond of friendship
and they want it they they they see how
meaningful it is and i i the way that i
make sense of it and the fan fiction is
that
it is a
it's taking something that is is very
real which is our
friendship our best friendship bond and
connection and there is a there is a
friendship platonic intimacy associated
with that and it is an unusual and very
intense and long friendship absolutely
and then people want to say well
it for some people to make sense of that
they say that there must be an unspoken
or
not public
romantic
or attraction sexual element
from my perspective
it's just never crossed
my mind i've never and i've never
observed
uh
desires welling up within myself to uh
of of attraction to you i gotta say i'm
not disappointed i'm sorry
uh but i will say a lot to try to make
myself uh attractive but that statement
also applies to
any other guy
straight gay whatever i just i i've
never observed within myself you're not
attracted to like jude law no
no i'm not i'd i've not experienced any
sexual attraction to
uh another guy
and i think people
people who see our relationship they
just they want to make sense of it and
and but people also desire
for
because we have this intimate friendship
they desire for us for it to for
there's a fantasy that for it to really
be
to go all the way it has to be
romantic
if not sexual yeah and i mean i don't
know i actually i don't i don't know
like i don't i don't know either but i
do think that like it's an opportunity
to say you know what you can you can be
in a devoted intimate friendship and it
never
come close to having a romantic or
sexual element because that's exactly
what's happening yeah and i think that
that is the
that is something that we're very proud
of and that we've come to grips with
being a cornerstone
of why people want to
want to enjoy proud of what you mean i'm
proud and i'm proud of not being gay no
i am i am proud of
being unabashedly
your intimate friend yeah of being your
best friend like even saying like
there's a vulnerability in saying you're
my best friend i love you as a friend
and there's nothing that you can do to
change that that we have a because if
you it's unlike anybody else but
and it doesn't have to be
uh romantic or sexual for it to be
extremely meaningful and i'm very proud
of what we have right and i think that's
enough but it's different it's an
important point that you're making which
is
because if you assume
that in order to really be
bonded with someone right it has to be
romantic and it has to be sexual what
you're doing is you're discounting the
intimacy that can come from a platonic
connection which is what what we have as
like a brotherhood a literal
blood bond like not literal brothers but
there wasn't enough we did a blood oath
um and i and i i i find that and i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna assume where that
comes from because it's not it's not me
and i don't know exactly why it happens
and again there's a point there's a part
of me that i think maybe 10 years ago
there was a part of me that was a little
irked by it
because i was like
i don't want people to think we're gay
i'll speak to that too but go ahead
that bothers me for some reason that i
haven't quite explored
now i'm in a place where i'm like well
if people think that we're gay and that
makes them like us more and want to
connect with us even more than so be it
maybe that's good for the brand
but again that's why i was a little
hesitant to answer the question but to
to want to be
honest and to to disclose the fact that
no i i don't think there's there would
be nothing wrong with the with us being
attracted to each other there would be
nothing it would be complicated we'd
have to figure that out
but no it's it's not a reality and i'll
get into like some
i'll get into a little bit more of my
own sexuality in a second but it sounds
like you want to talk to that one point
well i think that we're able to have as
deep of a friendship bond as we do
because
we are
our desires
are in the same place we're very
compatible in that way it would be i
agree there would be nothing wrong if
one of us had
a tinge of attraction for the other one
or had a desire for something more that
the other guy didn't want or vice versa
and then we just had to work through it
but it would create a little bit of
incompatibility in our hopes and desires
for what we have
but we don't have that
so i think that has been another
just that's played out in terms of us
being able to be secure and celebrate
our friendship because
our desires are the same yeah
agreed
now
there was a part of me that you know as
i have
evolved in terms of my worldview over
time you know first of all coming from a
purity culture coming from a place where
there wasn't like being the idea of
being gay was something that not only
was it wrong but it was like oh that's
gross like that was the environment that
we were raised in right yeah so the it
was unappealing like you didn't
you didn't want to even entertain the
idea that you might if i remember in
high school there was a kid who started
spreading a rumor that me and you were
gay
uh i don't know if you know if you
remember that vaguely remember in his
freshman year and i was so upset about
that and it ended up being this thing
that we had to go to the principal and
talk to him really yeah he had like
written he started writing like rhett
and link love each other or something
like on desks certain bathrooms or
something like that and like i
confronted him
about it and then so all that to say
i as i as my christian worldview fell
away i was like well i want to like
literally be i want to be honest with
myself like
do i am i have i been pushing something
down because of my my background and the
fact that it wasn't okay to be attracted
to men so therefore i wasn't willing to
entertain the idea of being attracted to
men because i was like if i'm just
honest with myself
there was never a point
and i used the jude law as an example as
kind of a joke but like a handsome man
like that i can recognize when a man is
handsome but there was never a point in
which i was like and i want to kiss him
or and i want to be close with him
sexually like
that has never crossed my mind but i was
like
am i repressing something right
and so i don't remember the first time
this was but i mean it's been years i
was like i'm gonna watch some gay porn
okay
i'm like i'm gonna do it i'm gonna watch
two dudes screw each other not only am i
a little bit interested and i mean i
gotta i know how it works i know that uh
the the penis goes in the the butt i
know that's how it works but i kind of
you know like let's let's watch that
happen
uh and let's get some on the scale of
attractiveness let's get some attractive
men and let's watch them have sex and
and and see if it does anything for us
like literally this is something that i
have done
and uh
i watched it
and was because here okay it's backing
up a little bit as it cut we're going to
talk about porn in a second but my
experience with porn had always been
oh i i'm into i'm into watching two
women have sex with each other that that
that's that's the point that i like i i
don't
let's not see that penis okay and again
i was like is that
is this something repressed like why do
i have a problem with a penis like am i
afraid that i'm gonna see a penis and be
like i want that penis and so this was
like a personal exploration
into this for for myself
and when i watched it i was like this is
interesting
um
those guys
look better than i do
um
but i do not have a desire to be there i
do not have a desire to be one of them i
don't find myself being
uh
sexually turned on and wanting to be a
part of this you didn't bookmark it i
did not bookmark it
and uh
you know i i at this point in my life
i'm okay with i'm okay with seeing a
penis right it's like it's it's it's
there's not like an aversion or i'm
scared of seeing it
but it's like i have as far as i know i
have plumbed the depths of myself
and come back with
i'm attracted to women
now one of the things that i have
learned about myself and i haven't done
a lot of research about this and i'm
sorry if i get terms wrong and this is
always you know but i am attracted to
trans women
right
so
um
when trans women are women that makes
sense that i would be attracted to women
but i i get that a trans woman
with a penis so like i've already
established how much i like vaginas and
specifically vulvas
i believe that it is almost like the
universe we've been down that road i
won't go down that road again
so yes i prefer a penis
freudian slip i prefer a vagina over a
penis
uh
but the thing is is i think that what
i'm ultimately attracted like if i was
i'm this isn't about to happen i'm in a
happy relationship with my wife
but let's just say i wasn't and there
was someone who was a trans woman that i
was attracted to because i i think i'm
attracted to sort of feminine traits and
the feminine presentation of someone
uh and i was like man i'm attracted to
this person sexually and we get along or
whatever and then i find out oh she has
a penis
i'd be like well i don't like a penis as
much as a vagina
uh
but would this be the end would this be
the end of the world and this would be
something that it
necessarily a showstopper i don't
honestly i don't know
um i kind of think i would miss i would
really miss the vagina but it's not that
the p it's not really the penis that's
that's the issue for me it's the fact
that i'm just not attracted to men
um does that make sense
yeah
yeah uh i mean i was just trying to
think of like
my own experience because i just i just
haven't thought about this stuff it's
like i just haven't been specifically
curious about it so it's again it's like
for me it's like this
i haven't observed
uh
those desires
welling up or the curiosity to find out
or like feel like
uh am i suppressing anything it's like i
just you know it doesn't uh
i'm very happy and i'm not uh
i just haven't found myself being
curious about whether i'm suppressing
anything but i feel pretty damn sure
that i'm not because i i value being
very open with myself and plumbing the
depths of what's in me yeah and well so
i guess all that i get all that i think
it's uh i think it's cool man i guess
all that to say
that we've never experimented with each
other and we haven't
thought about it
um
and i think i you know and i and i don't
i don't know what this is gonna do for
the
um for the people out there who just
ins i will i will say and again i'm
actually i'm not offended and i'm not
hurt by it but i will say
that in general the idea of
insisting and assuming
someone's sexual orientation
despite what they say like that's not
cool no it's not uh so it because they
switch that around and be like you got
somebody who's telling you that they're
gay and you're like no you're not you're
not gay you're straight i know you're
straight it's like that you think about
it like that that's not a cool thing to
do
individuals assert their own sexuality
you don't assert someone else's
sexuality again i know we're public
figures and it's fun for some people
don't stop writing the fan fiction if
you don't want to stop it but just i
wouldn't make a habit of asserting or
assuming someone's sexuality
if they are telling you something else
that's a not cool thing to do i think
one of my journeys that can
maybe can be observed i believe it can
be observed online that you described
that i also wanted to weigh in on was
yeah coming from where we came from in
like our fundamentalist beliefs about
being gay being wrong
and so
i was unwilling to make any jokes about
that or to
or
to
to
flirt with any humor around that area
between the two of us
and once i became very
accepting
and removed that judgment from my own
life
and mind
that made and that made me more secure
in in
in in who i am
and saying i'm not afraid if somebody
thinks that i'm gay or we're gay because
i don't it's not anything to be
embarrassed about right and that was a
shift that it was a journey
where i had to get to that point and i'm
very
glad i got to that point a byproduct of
it was that then
we could explore
the that relational tension for humor
that if people are assuming these things
or if we're as close as we are
like us exploring the tension
for comedy is funny because there's no
stakes if people think that we're gay
that that's who cares that so what is
what i've thought so it's a again it's a
it's another freedom of
like we can have fun in that area as
well when it comes to comedy but we also
don't and again i'm not i'm not super
schooled on this but like
we don't want to get into queer baiting
as well right i don't know queerbaiting
can mean a couple of different things
i've heard it defined a couple of
different ways but ultimately we don't
want to use someone's
assumption that we're gay
to
get you to click on something but like
we will play around with the like we
know that like two straight dudes doing
gay things like uh or gay-ish things
like when um
the kanye and kim video on the
motorcycle and then with seth rogen
right and james franco like did their
thing that was like there's a reason and
this is comedy duos have done this for
years it's like straight comedy duos
have done gay-ish type things for comedy
and i haven't really thought about that
too much and explored that but i don't
want to get into a place where we're
like
oh we the fact that you think we're gay
like we're trying to capitalize on that
no ironically
we're comfortable
you know
being
i just don't even know how to
characterize it because it's it's kind
of instinctual but it was something
that's like because we celebrate the
valid validity of being gay
or
and then
other things as well now right all of it
i accept the validity validity of all of
it that then it gives me a freedom to
say okay i don't need to try to
act like
i'm afraid that you're going to think
i'm something no we can just have fun
with this because it's just part of
it's it's an aspect of humanity yeah so
it's just more it's freedom but we are
never making fun
of a sexual orientation we're making fun
of to
if we're doing that like when we cuddle
the reason that that seems funny to us
is that what we don't cuddle right so
when two guys who don't cuddle do cuddle
right the awkwardness is funny right
right we don't think about it much more
than that yeah so hopefully that answers
that question uh
do with that what you will
last question um
from sex timber burner account
someone again hated a burner account for
this question since y'all have talked
about porn a lot in terms of growing up
how do you feel about porn now
especially with the gradual destination
stigmatization destigmatization of sex
work and usage of things like only fans
great question
um
i mean definitely when it comes to
there's a lot that like i personally
haven't
i haven't given too much thought
i this is still something that's
evolving for me and it's not something
that i've generated a lot of energy
towards
like figuring out like my stance so i
just want to go ahead and say that up
front i do think that comes from
um being steeped in teaching
that is like
fear porn
period
like stay as far away from porn as you
can it is dangerous
it like the only messages that i got
related to porn were negative right and
even so even to this point i i haven't
been really motivated to
explore
the positive
and empowering aspect of porn because i
personally
uh
i
i just haven't been motivated to do that
because i still i'm i've been steeped in
this i know that you can
it can be addictive and that it can
it can
serve an unhealthy
role in your in your life especially
when it relates to like
your sex your sex life with your partner
and it can impact that in a negative way
so i'm like
i'm not i don't find myself being really
motivated to figure out how to put how
to like really come to grips with porn
personally because i want
i want to devote my uh my energies more
to like cultivating my relationship with
christy and i and everything that we've
been presented with within the church
has only been negative and when they
would talk about it it would it would it
would be about the addiction
and you would have guys who would talk
about it publicly but they would talk
about it within the context of a former
addiction that they have been released
from and now are protect been currently
being protected from and protecting
themselves from and a lot of our account
accountability you would have somebody
who was like your accountability partner
or you were accountable to each other
like if you if you looked at porn it was
bad this was like this is like the
number one thing that christian dudes
are like confessing to each other yeah
oh i looked at pornography it became a
very
uh
heated fixation yeah to stay away from
it uh
like masturbation but it was even it was
even more obvious and could and it felt
like
very deadly but i have this sneaking
suspicion that
it that you can't you can't just apply
those principles as a blanket statement
i mean it's just like
like the vilification of
of alcohol
it's like saying that you can't consume
alcohol at all because you will be
addicted well everybody's not addicted
to alcohol everybody's not addicted to
gambling i think this is a really good
analogy but i don't wanna so
i have this
i am open
to
that also being true of pornography well
that's one of the beautiful things about
abandoning a world view it's not easy it
was tough it was the toughest thing i've
ever done but the sort of being able to
examine something new in a new light and
on its own face and you know
and i think that i have thought a little
bit about this and i've not extensively
and i haven't like read a whole lot
about it and i don't have a lot of
research but i kind of see this as
there's three aspects of this right
there's the the nature of porn itself
and that's when and then there's your
personal relationship with porn and then
there's porn as it relates to your
relationship with your significant other
so the first aspect i'm not gonna talk a
whole lot about but i do think that you
know there's an ethical porn movement
right now and more and more people are
being sort of in because traditionally
there was a lot of people involved in
porn who
were kind of being coerced there's
people who are sex trafficked and then
brought into porn i don't know what the
statistics are but i know that
there was an unhealthy environment and
maybe i'd say continues to be an
unhealthy environment and maybe some not
a lot of consent involved in some
coercion but we are kind of moving into
a place where there's more of sort of a
personally empowered whether that be
like cam girls or only fans or that kind
of thing where it's just like hey i'm a
sex worker i'm presenting myself in a
pornographic way to my fans no one's
asked no one's forcing me into this i'm
doing it it's a i am in control i am in
control
so i think that i'm all for ethical porn
and how that's parsed is not something
i'm an expert in but i would say that i
do believe that when it comes to issues
of health again it's a health framework
not a moral framework for me and so is
there a way for somebody to be a sex
worker in that way in a healthy way
i think yes and is there a way so
if you're watching porn
that
isn't
you can make choice
you can make choices that will that will
uh
that will support empowerment or
support the the negative aspects of the
industry which is you know and i don't
know how much of that but i think
again i don't know how much is bad and
but you can you can make an ethical
investigation and then uh make a
decision where you consume that's
important that that supports a healthy
industry but the thing is more
interesting to me is is your personal
relationship with porn and then your
relationship as it you know as it is in
in the context of a relationship you
probably have to pay for that porn i'm
assuming uh like i don't know maybe i
don't know
well yeah well yeah like only fans or
whatever yeah um so
this is sort of again this is sort of an
evidence-based approach to to this and
not coming from the evangelical mindset
one thing i do know for a fact is that
the access that we have to
sexually explicit
images videos experiences that we can
visually interact with or maybe even
interact with in like a vr setting like
we can have a sensory
experience
it's not something that our brains
adapted to be able to handle
uh
our brains and our bodies evolved in the
context of
you know again this is stone age
hardware and then we've got this
the modern day software that's running
on them and i think that your brain is
not really equipped to see
500 vaginas over the course of a week
okay now
in one video
well there's probably one like there's
probably an orgy video with 500 people i
don't know what the record is
but i do think that there is something
to the idea
that extreme visual sexual
um
experience
and sort of sensory experience
i don't know if we've quite figured out
the impact that that is having on us
culturally right and it's having on us
as people there are plenty of people who
will say
that listen
yes you can get addicted to this yes you
can
replace a healthy sexual interaction in
person with a uh online only sexual
relationship
and but there's also things like
expectations for your partner if i'm
having sex with my wife
but i am experiencing sexual
uh having sexual experiences with all
these other women out there and
basically anything that i could ever
possibly imagine
for me personally it's kind of
impossible for me not to carry some
expectations
into my relationship with jesse right
so does that mean that i i if porn is
completely off limits for me no
does it mean that i'm going to look at
it whenever i want whenever i get the
urge no because i do believe that that i
don't think that's going to have a great
effect on me personally
so
kind of where i stand on the issue in
terms of like how i interact with it is
just like do do have i sworn off porn
all together no
if i am going to look
can i look at it by myself
in in in the context of my marriage with
jessie yes can she look at it by herself
in the context of our marriage yes she
can
um
but is it something that is going to be
a regular thing that replaces my sexual
interaction with jesse no because i have
a limited amount of sexual energy i mean
i like to think of myself as having a
lot of sexual energy but i have a
limited amount of sexual energy and am i
going to be devoting that to myself and
this sort of intimate experience with
someone on a screen when i have someone
who oh this could be something this
energy is something i could devote and
direct towards jesse
so you got to be careful about that yeah
i do that that makes that makes sense to
me like the alcohol example
there's lots of things like as a
responsible
autonomous person i got to figure out
what my what is a healthy relationship
with all types of things that can be
very unhealthy and addictive and i think
it's interesting you know as a we came
up in a different time
where
we had basically been through puberty
and right we're almost sexually active
like getting married by the time like
porn became this thing and definitely
you could get it on your phone you could
see any kind of sexual act that you want
to on your phone like that's a new thing
our kids are coming up
in the context of of that exactly so we
talk about that it's a yeah and it's a
totally different conversation
i'm not trying to attach shame to it but
i just want you to understand that like
if your only sexual outlet is porn
you know
i do i do think it's a generational
issue right now where there's just so
many kids who are experiencing their
only sexual experience is not it's not
an interpersonal thing it's a internet
thing
and i just i haven't done the research
and i don't know all the stats but my
inclination is that that's not a good
thing for us culturally is that we need
to be making connections with each other
but speaking of the connections with
each other and is there a role for porn
in the context of a healthy relationship
i think maybe again i think that this is
based on consent and this is based on
agreement between you and your partner
and i will say
that on
a few occasions
jesse and i have experimented with like
what would it be like for us to look at
porn together as we are about to or as
we are engaging in sex with each other
and it's something we've done a couple
of times a few times and
it's been pretty cool
and also most of the time it's like
we've kind of like it's been humorous as
we've kind of like laughed because porn
tends to be kind of funny even when
they're trying not to be
um but it could be the kind of thing
it's just like hey let's do what they're
doing
oh let's imitate what they're doing it
to me there's an element of it that's
just like it creates sort of an openness
around the idea of sex and um
can be a fun addition to the sexual menu
that you have with your partner but but
it isn't the kind of thing it can
inspire yeah but again that was a that
was a decision that we made that i i
don't even know who brought it up and i
don't even remember i think the time
that it finally happened it may have
been i don't i'm not i don't want to
speak for jesse i i don't remember how
it happened but it wasn't like me like
sitting around me like when you want to
watch florida you want to watch porn
together i want to watch porn together
with you and i definitely don't use that
voice ever with my wife
gross
yeah it's not something that christy and
i have ever
ever done because it's just something
that hasn't come up my main point about
porn is that because you can interact
with porn and have a fully
self-contained sexual experience
introducing that into a relationship i
believe you can run the risk of becoming
dependent upon that and not having an
experience with one another
whether that means you're have you're
engaging in uh porn and masturbation
apart from your partner and directing
your sexual energy there and so
therefore you're not giving it to your
partner or
you're now together in experiencing porn
but all your attention is being directed
towards the screen versus the other
person and something about the intimacy
is broken
so i'm not saying i've got it figured
out and that my way is better i think
you've got it figured out for you well i
don't well i don't know that i mean me
and jesse may decide that like we don't
want that at all and the moment she
tells me i'm not comfortable with this i
don't like this anymore it's the moment
that i say well we don't do it anymore
right
and so
the conversations that we have i hope
inspire
partners listening to have conversations
but it did
more so than inspire people to do the
things that we're doing or not right
it's more about that communication like
you said like i'm not like i don't want
you to be like well all right now we got
to do this because you said that you did
it right it's about that i mean first of
all the question is about porn and i
think we we answered it that there there
is such a thing as ethical porn there we
do think that there are pitfalls when it
comes to porn personally and there are
pitfalls when it comes to porn
relationally but also it can be an
enhancement in a lot of ways but it's
complicated it's complex and it's you
can't paint it with a broad brush it's
individual and it's also the consent
aspect both in terms of porn itself like
are the people who are doing these
things are they consenting to the
situation but also in the context of
your relationship is there consent and
understanding and communication
if you if you make sure you're on the
right side of the issue when it comes to
all those things you'll just avoid so
many pitfalls we haven't even talked
about parenting i i don't want to go too
deep into this but i do want to
acknowledge that like as kids get
older
and they go through puberty
you find yourself having to deal with
okay
porn is such
a it it it just emanates from everywhere
uh and it's so it's it can't just be
do not
[Music]
do not have anything to do with it never
see it well because you're not that's
not going to be successful just not
going to be successful you have to
figure out a way to say
these are the dangers
associated with it you're not going to
be able to avoid it entirely but you
need to be
you need to maintain
your own power
and not give that over and that actually
pornography
for me that is when i'm not just like
saying it's bad and i don't want to be a
part of it but when i say well maybe
there's aspects of it that are good and
i actually need to engage with it and
process that
to me that actually cuts down on my
total consumption of it because it makes
me engage with it in a thoughtful way
yes and i think that
as opposed to tell your kids it's wrong
they're going to do it anyway and
they're going to feel guilty and they're
never going to talk to you and they're
going to keep doing it and they're going
to potentially become reliant on it
right and and i i think this could that
principle could apply
uh in terms of like conversations with
your partner as well but back to the
kids i mean yes i put filters
on my kids internet so that the so that
they couldn't stumble on porn or they
couldn't get to it if they were curious
and they wanted to but at a certain age
you start
to realize that they're going to find a
way to see it even if you even if they
can't see it on everything that you have
control over in your house yeah and so
you have to go further you have to have
these open conversations
it's when it starts with i'm putting
this thing on your computer and your
phone
that
we use kaspersky
kids safe app
and it worked
really well but
that's to protect kids until they get to
an age where it's like
now there's not
you're gonna see it you gotta figure out
how to how to deal with it and we gotta
have that conversation you can't have
you can't you just can't have a filter
on make them have a filter for the rest
of their lives they're going to have to
make that decision for themselves yeah
and yeah i think that that
i don't know it to me it's it's one of
the most exciting things it's
it requires more effort honestly
just like we were saying with jesse and
christie it's it was easier as an
evangelical christian to be like here's
the framework that has been figured out
and i'm gonna just put it down on you
and
that's easier from a parenting
standpoint
but they're like hey let's actually
engage with this like you're an
individual you have certain inclinations
and you're a certain type of person
how will you interact with this thing
whatever it might be
yeah can we have an ongoing conversation
about that and what's healthy for you
um it makes it different from kid to kid
the
relationships and the opportunities the
inclinations are different from child to
child
and it just becomes more involved and it
takes more time
and it's more process oriented than it
is
sort of rule oriented
um but it's the only it's the only way i
know to do it at this point
um
but yeah that's
that's porn okay and that's our last
question so i mean do you have a wreck
because i was gonna i was gonna
piggyback on that but what's your rag
uh
i have a wreck that again my wrecks tend
to not be related to what we're talking
about
um
which may or may not be satisfying so if
you have a wreck that is related to what
we're talking about yeah i was going to
run on youtube i've read i think i've
written this about
or said it so yeah i'm going to
recommend mypleasure.com if you
because it gives you it's an educational
website where you can buy sex toys of
all types and you can read
from qualified
people
uh including doctors i believe
about how to use these things
appropriately and
it's it's a great educational site that
then if you want to sidestep the
pornography part of it that's the
principle of the site is that there's
none of that so it's it's separate we
didn't talk a lot separates porn from
sex toys and it simplifies that equation
so you can and you can be educated and
be adventurous yeah because we didn't we
didn't play a lot about toys i mean we
talked about toys
incidentally but
we're both very big proponents of sex
toys i mean when you've been again when
you've been married for 20 years one of
the one of the ways that you continue to
keep things spicy is you introduce new
things into the bedroom and that's part
of one of the great things about growing
old and and you want to make that
learning about yourself and your and
your partner yeah so yeah i'm on board
for my pleasure and i'll just do my
other wreck uh next week okay in the
meantime we do want to remind you about
good mythical evening again we've been
talking a lot about sex we're going to
talk about sex on good mythical evening
and we're going to do a lot of other
things
adult stuff it is the adult themed
ticketed live event
on october 28th uh you can get tickets
at goodmythicalevening.com
it's a good mythical morning we're just
just all censorship removed yeah which
is something we're not uh able to do on
youtube that's not something we don't
want to change what good mythical
morning is but this will be fun but we
want to do something a little bit
different uh just on good mythical
evening
goodmythicalevening.com your biscuits
let us know as we wrapped up sex timber
what you think about it and uh we'll
talk at you next week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]